all right to Hector Garza right now the
national uh border patrol Council vice
president Hector you keep telling us
about this and Bill malusion keeps
reminding us about this but very little
action uh on the part of anyone in
Washington to do something about this
what do you do
well it's it's quite clear that the
floodgates at the southern border are
wide open for illegal immigration and
for drugs Smugglers uh unfortunately the
solution here is it's going to be a
brand new presidential Administration
that actually has the willpower to
actually want to secure the border and
save American lives and save lives of
those uh migrants that come across the
border illegally uh quite frankly it's
just out of control of the border and
then we're tired and I don't know how
much longer we can go with with this uh
secretary board and with this crisis I
just wonder it's gotten increasingly
bold and you were the first to remind me
of how bold it gets and you could see it
on some of the Drone footage we got
where even looking at cameras and drones
and like the the March goes on and is
unabated and I'm just wondering where
you see this going I mean we just had
2.3 2.4 million maybe up to 3 million
including gotaways and illegal migrants
through the country where does this
number go
well it's just racing and and I want to
point out that that even though the CBP
are reported
um about 600 000 gotaways those are
people those are illegal aliens that
cross into the country legally and and
uh invaded capture those are only the
numbers that we know of and that the
administration is actually reporting on
we know the boots on the ground that the
numbers is almost double that uh because
we know we have areas along the border
where we have absolutely zero border
patrol agents here in the Border if you
talk about the northern border if you
talk about the coastal border uh we have
very very limited Manpower so we know
that That Got Away number is actually
skyrocketing is is higher and even
double than what is being reported but
there's no end inside and unfortunately
uh American Labs are being lost and
unfortunately this is going to continue
to happen until we get a new
Administration and somebody actually
cares about about the border and cares
about migrants and cares about the
American people Hector will watch it
closely thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else